you know i've been having a lot of fun
with my new research tool um called
illicit.org
if you haven't heard about this it's a
great
search engine that allows you to
reach out to
200 million papers to find
information that is very difficult to
find when you do just general google
searches and of course i did a deep dive
on apple cider vinegar i wanted to see
if there's any additional benefits that
i haven't mentioned in other videos now
the main acid in apple cider vinegar is
called acetic acid
and
your
microbes make acetic acid in fact acetic
acid is the most abundant
short chain fatty acid now what do i
mean short chain fatty acid well your
microbes by digesting fiber
make this byproduct and it just so
happens that acetic acid is one of them
in fact it's the one that's over 50
so yes vinegar is a type of fatty acid
which is fascinating so this acetic acid
is like fuel for your colon cells in
other words 70
of the energy
that is needed from your colon cells
are received from these short chain
fatty acids and our human cells get
about 10 percent of its energy from
these short chain fatty acids and this
is why i mentioned in other videos that
apple cider vinegar can improve your
energy now you know why and in the other
videos i talked about the benefits of an
apple cider vinegar or your blood sugars
okay decreasing the ph to make things
more acidic to decrease pathogens
because it's a very powerful
antimicrobial and because it helps
insulin resistance it can help
lipids cholesterol triglycerides
fatty liver and of course this relates
to a lessening of your belly fat as well
as decreasing your appetite
and improving overall digestion
but let's talk about the benefits that
you may have never heard about number
one the acetic acid and apple cider
vinegar
is a very potent anti-inflammatory
especially
in your gut
so of course you would want to dilute
apple cider vinegar with water like a
maybe a teaspoon or a tablespoon you're
not going to drink it down in its
concentrated form because that's going
to irritate your tissues so we're just
talking about diluting this acid number
two apple cider vinegar
helps support mucin which is
part of the
immune barrier in your colon
to help regulate the immune system and
keep the pathogens from crossing this
very important barrier so apple cider
vinegar can help prevent a leaky gut
number three apple cider vinegar has
additional things not just acetic acid
it has what's called phenolic compounds
like catechin
caffic acid gallic acid etc etc now
these compounds
actually have the potential to inhibit
the formation of beta amyloids in
alzheimer's patients the plaquing in
your brain these compounds also
significantly can improve your cognitive
function and number four and this is
interesting certain medical procedures
actually use acetic acid
to inject directly into tumors
to shrink them so acetic acid and apple
cider vinegar has an anti-cancer effect
number five acetic acid in alps of
vinegar can prevent the overgrowth of
candida in someone's dentures number six
it can be used for fungus in the ear
this is called otomycosis where this
fungus or candida is is living in the
external part of your ear number seven
apple cider vinegar is beneficial for
something called a topic
dermatitis
so it helps inflammation of your skin of
course you're going to dilute apple
cider vinegar maybe a teaspoon and a 12
ounce glass of water and then apply that
to your skin it can help reduce
inflammation so not only is apple cider
vinegar good
for the immune barrier in your gut but
the immune barrier on your skin number
eight i found a study that showed that
apple cider vinegar can help inhibit
plaque formation in your arteries that's
wild and number nine apple cider vinegar
is hepatoprotective
it helps protect the liver against
certain heavy metals like cadmium and
aluminum
and also helps protect the liver against
certain unfriendly microbes so apple
cider vinegar is just an amazing home
remedy that you can use for a lot of
different things now if you haven't seen
my video on apple cider vinegar the one
that got
14 million views
i put it up right here check it out